hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
edition of ask Evan in today's episode
I'm going to answer a question from one
of my newsletter readers surrender who
has an aluminum door company he targets
business owners with it and he's
sourcing it from Italy and he's now
trying to brand this company and be
known as the god who provides aluminum
doors and one of my advice on how to do
that so thanks for the question
surrender first off I would try to add
an extra word an extra qualifier on
there so you not just notice a guy
provides aluminum doors but the guy who
provides the best quality aluminum doors
or the lowest price aluminum doors or
you provide the most options and
aluminum doors or the best service for
aluminum doors so that it makes it a
little bit easier to remember that way
when people are in business to you they
can say oh yeah music I provides the
best quality aluminum doors now you are
not ideally going after the lowest price
it's the hardest competitive advantage
to sustain over a long period of time
and if you're sourcing your product in
Italy chances are it's not going to be a
low-cost type of product so go for
something like quality or service a
number of options that will help you
know kind of make you stand out also
being the guy who sells b2b can help us
well some people are referring you is
easier to pass qualified leads on to you
and they're more likely to think about
you a certain situation because they
remember that you're the guy who
provides the best quality aluminum doors
for b2b people the next thing I would
try to do is network with people who can
make multiple or bulk orders from you so
if you go out and try to sell individual
orders to individual business owners you
know that could make some money but it's
a hard tough road to do because a lot of
these guys may never buy from you again
or if they do they may buy for you in
five years or ten years then off you
have to replace an aluminum door but
you're providing quality product so
hopefully they will have to replace it
that often instead I would try to target
guys like builders might be building big
buildings and need a lot of aluminum
doors or guys like architects who
may not be designing you know huge
buildings but have a lot of projects on
the go and can can keep bringing you
customers on an ongoing basis so you
want to kind of go up to those guys and
it's worth investing the time with their
relationship and for them to get to know
you and how great a product that you
provide so that it can help you know
boost business right away bring cash
flow in and help you you'll continue to
grow your business a lot easier to do
that when you go after you know business
owners one by one by one the last thing
I we try to do is over deliver on
everything that you do so the best way
to get referrals is to over-deliver and
really wow the customer so how can you
go over the top to really provide a
great experience for your customers if
you are talking to architects and
builders how can you provide such an
awesome experience with them that they
want to keep using you so you know
you're you're always early for the job
your guys are in uniform looking really
nice maybe there's a follow up you can
do as a process to make sure that the
doors are installed properly and the
customers are really happy with it think
of extra way so you can really wow the
customer that they're not expecting
you're not used to you give little
presents every time that they order from
you whatever it is think of different
ways you can stand out with them so that
you're you're really blowing their mind
and they really want to work with you
again and they're going to tell all
their friends about you you're not just
an average supplier like all the other
guys I deal with you're the guy who
really over delivers and does what he
says it's going to do so that's a great
way to get referrals hopefully that
helps to run there if you guys like the
video please give it a thumbs up below I
love seeing those thumbs up coming in
and I'd also love to hear what you have
to think if you want to leave a comment
under the video please leave it for help
for surrender or just to say what you
thought of the video so thank you and i
will see you next episode
you